[Music]
it's the human behavior
that is making the brain of the machine
that is how you make the machine
intelligent
today on chalk radio how the future of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning education might look a lot more
human what's the difference between
saying you know a restaurant review
expresses positive sentiment which is a
very complicated social phenomenon and
saying that you know a picture of the
number nine is a picture of the number
nine which is much less complicated as a
social phenomenon
i'm your host sarah hansen
this week we're talking with three
interdisciplinary collaborators about
their mission to foster a new kind of
approach to computing technologies
they've created an assignment that
challenges students to take a critical
approach as they build the technologies
of the future
i am catherine dignizio
i am an assistant professor of urban
science and planning
my name is jacob andreas i'm an
assistant professor in the department of
electrical engineering and computer
science and also the computer science
and artificial intelligence laboratory
my name is harini suresh i'm a fifth
year phd student in computer science
in spring 2021 catherine jacob and
harini were brought together as part of
a special initiative called cirque from
the mit stephen a schwarzman college of
computing
circ stands for the social and ethical
responsibilities of computing
the mission broadly is thinking about
how do we cultivate responsible creators
of computational tools and technologies
for the folks who are going to go out
and be building the tools of the future
you know in a lot of cases you don't
know what the ethical implications of
something are until you know a kind of
more abstract tool or technology or
algorithm is kind of like plugged into
the human context right like that place
where you know the machine learning and
people
meet
there have been lots of high profile
incidents involving things like face
recognition software people trying to
deploy machine learning systems in the
contents of things like sentencing or
recidivism prediction and in many cases
having sort of seriously harmful effects
for jacob exploring the social
consequences of ai got him to start
thinking a little differently in his own
survey course
6.864
natural language processing or nlp for
short
the way we have traditionally taught
machine learning classes it's always
okay you know here's a data set of you
know photographs of digits classify this
picture as whether it contains you know
a zero or a one or a two or a three and
you know here's a data set of restaurant
reviews and they just happen to already
have assigned to them labels for whether
this is a positive restaurant review or
a negative restaurant review you know go
train the machine learning model and at
no point do you stop and ask okay but
where did these
restaurant reviews come from and what's
the difference between saying you know a
restaurant review
expresses positive sentiment which is a
very complicated social phenomenon and
saying that you know a picture of the
number nine is a picture of the number
nine which is much less complicated as a
social phenomenon
[Music]
so we teamed up with catherine and
harini to show students that the machine
part of machine learning is very much
influenced by humans
so the way that machine learning systems
work in many cases is something called
supervised learning where the data set
contains examples as well as labels for
those examples so for example in
content moderation you might have in
your data set
comments from a message board as well as
annotations that say this is a toxic
comment or this is not a toxic comment
so then what the machine learning system
is trying to do is
learn from that data what makes up a
toxic comment what are characteristics
of toxicity
and
it uses the annotations to figure that
out and those annotations typically come
from somewhere so they might be
automatically generated by looking at
historically what sorts of comments have
been moderated
or they might be generated by people
you might crowdsource this or get
specific
groups of people to annotate comments as
to whether they think they're toxic or
non-toxic and those would become the
labels in the data set that the machine
learning system would learn from
we need to train it basically and the
way to train it is you look either like
harry set out historical data or you
make your own data set where you and
your team are you in a group of people
or you hire people to say this is toxic
this is not toxic or let's keep this one
let's not keep that one and that
that annotation
that is how you make the machine
intelligent and so if we back up a
little bit it's the human behavior
that is making the brain of the machine
that's why you know that step is really
important in there that that human
step is also the step that we were
trying to tune people into as not just
being this like this objective thing
that the the machine makes up by itself
based on completely objective parameters
or whatever
people take these classes and then they
go out in the real world and find
themselves building detectors for even
more complicated things like like these
toxicity detectors and that was what
really felt like the sort of gap between
the way we were training people and the
way these tools were getting deployed in
practice
together they designed a brand new
assignment for the course
one they hoped would get students
thinking about the human element of
machine learning
first students wrote instructions for
annotating data sets and then they tried
to follow each other's instructions
the overall goal of the assignment was
to try and get students to go from
thinking about data as this pre-existing
objective ground truth to thinking about
it as the product of
a long and complex process that involves
many steps and is driven by human
judgments and values the goal of this
assignment is not to say that data is
not useful or that it's bad but rather
to help students critically think about
data sets when they receive them or use
them or hear about them being used and
to help them
sort of ask those questions of who is
this created by how is it created what
are its capabilities and what are its
limitations
when katherine harini and jacob started
reading the students responses they
realized that the assignment helped
students think differently about the
instructions they were giving annotators
but it also did something none of them
had expected
the thing that surprised me most was the
number of students who said
i've never done an assignment like this
in my whole undergraduate or graduate
training right and this is an advanced
class these are people who are seniors
in college or in their first or second
year of graduate school
and for many people it was really the
first time they'd actually been asked to
sort of think about the process by which
these data sets that they've been seeing
since you know their sophomore year
were actually being generated
initially we
had designed this to focus on
subjectivity that annotators might have
so like subjectivity in labels and data
sets but there were a bunch of other
things that people learned about the
entire
data set pipeline so for example the
categorizations that people came up with
for the same problem were drastically
different in some cases
people were sort of surprised by how
much personal judgment they had to use
to decide these things
everyone was like wow i was very
surprised by the amount
that i wasn't sure and the amount that i
had to sort of rely on
my own
biases or
judgments to decide what i actually
thought about this
and these students reflections actually
pointed to much bigger questions within
the field as a whole
of the numerous ways that uh hereini and
catherine mentioned of constructing
these data sets one that has become i
think particularly important within the
machine learning research community
these days is crowdsourcing right where
there's some sort of online
portal where people can log in and sign
up for a you know teeny little labeling
task like just look at this one
picture and tell me whether or not
there's a picture of a cat or look at
this one
comment and tell me whether it's a toxic
comment or not and then you get five
cents or ten cents in exchange for doing
this little micro task
so there's two sorts of things to think
about when using these kinds of
platforms one is just thinking about the
well-being of the annotators themselves
right that it's very easy to
miscalibrate the amount of time that it
takes to do one of these micro tasks and
wind up not actually paying people a
living wage for doing them and there are
actually people all over the world who
rely on these kinds of crowdsourcing
platforms as their primary source of
income and another thing you know once
you again start to think about tasks
like toxic comment detection or even
more sensitive things like recognizing
images of pornography or images of
violence or whatever it is
relatively easy you know without you as
the sort of system builder yourself
having had to look at any of this data
to dump just an enormous amount of like
really traumatizing content on
people who you're paying 10 cents a pop
to label and there's all kinds of
studies showing that you know people
really experience post-traumatic stress
disorder various other kinds of mental
health issues when subjected to these
kinds of things
in our conversation this notion of
context kept coming up
the context in which data are created
pulled from and annotated is incredibly
important when thinking about how to
improve machine learning systems
one thing that comes to mind is desmond
patton's lab at columbia he works on
like context aware annotations of social
media data so specifically
the work of his that i've read is around
twitter
so looking at tweets and specifically
tweets in inner city chicago and they
the task that they're trying to do is
analyze tweets from gang involved youth
in chicago and if you look at some of
these tweets they're trying to annotate
them with things like whether they're
violent or whether they indicate that
there's like a violent event going on
and if you were to just read them
without any awareness of the context and
try to annotate them something that
seems like it super violent if you
actually were in the context and
were part of that community you might
know that it's like a lyric from a local
rapper or something that requires a lot
of community specific
expertise
so what they did in this project was
actually get experts from the community
to look through this data and do
context-aware annotation and they found
that they were able to
do like a much better analysis of this
data that was much more accurate and
grounded in the actual
context that it was a part of so that's
i think one example where if you were to
just apply like generic tools you would
really fail at this task
there are problems pieces that are
slightly
less culturally fraught where there's
less room for
stereotypes bias
pre-existing structural inequalities to
enter into like if we're training a
system to recognize numbers in an image
you know what i mean that is just
there's less there's less room i mean
obviously there's still going to always
be space for interpretation but like
there's less room
because like we don't have pre-existing
conceptions of number nine's
unworthiness or something like this
right
but it's more when we enter into data
about using human language or that is
being used for decision making systems
that have real life consequences for
human beings so for training resume
screeners for example so like systems
where a large company would do an
automated system to screen resumes and
then only put the top ones you know up
to the the humans or whatever
we're baking in a lot of biases in the
process and that has to do with where
the data are coming from it also has to
do with who are labeling the data and
then who are
developing the the technologies and it's
not because they're evil you know like
it's not because there's bad people at
all stages of this pipeline it's that we
haven't we haven't sufficiently kind of
trained people along the way
there are tools to deal with bias
stereotypes structural inequalities but
they just they come from other
disciplines so how do we bring those
things together
to ultimately develop a more robust
system that works better for everybody
but just because the data are not the
subjective ground truth doesn't mean
like we just
throw up our hands or like forget about
it we can never do anything it just
means we have to enter with more caution
and more transparency and reflexivity
around what are
the boundaries and the applications of
the knowledge that we're producing
i asked jacob harini and catherine what
they'd like to hear from you our
listeners about how to help students
take a critical approach to computing
one question that i have
that i've been thinking about is
what's the right format to
introduce students to these concerns so
in this case we did an assignment within
a machine learning class
and i wonder
like how does that compare to sort of
having it be a small portion of every
assignment instead of just one
assignment or how does that compare to
having
a class that's like more primarily
dedicated to social and ethical concerns
this is my eternal thing with these
classes there's like how do you
weave in the critical while still giving
people like empowering people with tools
to to ultimately change practices and
also to change the tools eventually too
because the tools don't in themselves
also work perfectly they all have their
own politics so if people have ideas
about how do you both build skills but
also
have them interrogating
tools interrogating politics the
critical context in which the tools are
used i would love feedback or ideas
around that
if you have insights to share about
engaging students in thinking about the
social and ethical responsibilities in
computing
please get in touch with us at the link
in our show notes
and when you do you'll be joining
catherine harini and jacob in
spotlighting just how human the digital
world is
if you're interested in learning from
their open and free teaching materials
or remixing them in your own teaching
you can find them on our mit open
courseware website
thank you so much for listening
until next time signing off from
cambridge massachusetts i'm your host
sarah hansen from mit opencourseware
chalk radio's producers include myself
red pachy and dave lachansky
scriptwriting assistance from aubrey
callaway show notes for this episode
were written by peter chipman
the circ resource site on ocw was built
by kathleen nalazetti
we're funded by mit open learning and
supporters like you